I gotta ask you about Silicon Valley
okay let's hear it can we talk about
that so of course uh your character
Ehrlich Bachmann gotta do it okay boom
everyone knows this guy uh what I loved
about Silicon Valley is I actually just
recently interviewed Kevin Connolly E
from Entourage did you yeah he's great
dude shout out to you Kev yeah but by
the way so like Silicon Valley kind of
reminds me of the Entourage of like Tech
Bros Silicon Valley yeah I think that
was a little bit of it and it's almost
like
Wahlberg's character and Entourage was
sort of strangely
um Thomas middleditch but from the
beginning they the two of the guys that
created the show so funny all true and
krinsky and John altruler kind of said
the show is not about
Richard the main character he's like
it's about Richard and Ehrlich because
it's kind of a Wozniak Stephen
100 and you know and you were the one
sorrow world no I'm the Steve Jobs
believe it yeah Richard is good with the
tech and he's actually building he's the
engineer
and I'm sort of the face of the
incubator but after a while it was
um you know none of the they had built
this thing where none of the guys really
liked Ehrlich and there is no reason for
him to be involved so more and more the
writers were like how do we make it so
that Ehrlich has to still be on the show
type of thing so at four years I was
like
they had wrote this thing that was
really really funny about me going to an
opium den and Gavin Belson paying for me
to just do opium there forever and I was
like I want to leave the show and HBO
was like what do you mean and they were
like uh welcome back you know don't you
want to do you can just do three
episodes a season or something like that
yeah I was like no I think it's really
funny if this is how erla kind of gets
killed off in the show not the Opium Den
yeah and so that was so funny to me and
the re the reason was it was really
funny
real reason was was I was just like
kind of starting going autopilot I'd
been this this character for five years
right and you know he's a total Stoner
and had gotten to the point where I
could have gotten totally high and just
walked my way through this stuff and
collected a check and that's it and
that's not what I'm going to do I was
doing which most people would have stand
up yeah I have a joke where like not HBO
but Hollywood was kind of like wait a
second
you want to leave the show and I'm like
yeah and I don't you want a boat not
really and I was like what and this is
just a mentality yeah yeah so in their
mind they're like well don't you more
stuff more stuff more stuff right I was
like no I want to live in New York with
my wife and do stand up and they're like
but have you ever been on a boat yeah
type of thing so I sort of said I think
this is the right time to leave this
thing and that's another thing is I
think you've got to know when to exit
you know it's not even know when to hold
them in one and know when to fool them
you always want to leave when you're a
little bit uncomfortable as to what you
would do after you leave because once
you get to the point where you're like I
should have left right it's all that
moment that moment puts you in a place
where you're always thinking backwards
instead of forwards instead of
scrambling yourself and being like okay
I'm leaving this thing I don't know what
it's gonna be like we'll figure it out
let's go and you're that makes you so
focused but what I would say to
everybody who's watching right now and
thinking ah yeah that's me I'm always
thinking about it then just write now
begin the process of leaving I guess
what TJ thank you I quit guys
with this I'm not going to say there's a
major franchise that I felt like I
needed to do with that
um and then pretty much everything in my
life except for stand-up because
stand-up changes every night so it's
never the same you never have the same
job description unless your guy is doing
the same thing over and over and over
and you film a special then over and
over and over and over and over and you
film a special but that's not me because
I want people to come to show and be
like dude I should come again on Sunday
because it's going to be so different if
he's doing what he's doing here can I
can I add to what you're saying can I
break down I have a saying that every
constantly it's on my desk it says your
comfort zone will kill you I saw that if
you're just getting too comfortable you
can all of a sudden you get lazy you get
kind of like you forget the hunger you
forget the drive of what's going on like
what you said is almost like reminiscent
of what happens with athletes sometimes
they they they get out of the game a
little too late they say well you know
yeah I'll keep going and like for
instance
um if you get out on top you're on top
like you want a championship well enough
time came back yeah you get out on top
you're killing it you're at a top show
on HBO you were hungry people are
wanting you you know this as a comedian
you sometimes you'll tell a funny joke
all right guys have a great night you
always kind of end where things are
going well rather you know in an
ascending or even top over the Pinnacle
rather than on the way down there's kind
of like a sad drop off there like oh he
didn't know how to he should have
retired a year ago he should have left a
year ago people are so nice but a lot of
people come to me they go yeah I kind of
stopped watching after you left and it's
like I didn't really sit and watch the
rest of the show that was yeah why why
that wasn't the intention though but I
wish them all the best and I wanted
Jimmy o Yang who is the Chinese guy I
know Jimmy I know Jimmy so funny what a
great guy I wanted him to have more
space I wanted Thomas middleditch to
have more space himself to like grow as
because he is so funny I used to work
from Chicago he's one of the funniest
want to face the planet especially with
improv it's fine she can be on the phone
it doesn't matter
um and so uh I but I do feel like I did
exactly what you're saying I left on top
I left when the show was still fresh
still great I had already won a Critics
Choice Award oh yeah been nominated for
another it was
um it was really fun but I was hosting
Awards shows I was doing all that kind
of stuff and I feel like you're gonna
see there's another thing that I'm not
involved in that I think it was a really
good idea not to sort of step into that
and I also kind of I Kate always says
this is exactly what you're saying but
she loves this quote by David Bowie that
he feels creatively his best when he's
out to see just to the point where his
toes can't quite touch the ground oh I
love that you can feel it a little bit
but then but then as the currents oh she
loses comfort zone will kill you yeah
and but not to go so far not to stop and
not do this and then okay I left Silicon
Valley guys I'm gonna do a really really
serious drama about a gay father and his
gay son coming out to each other that's
that
it's dropping what 2023
I'm saying sort of yeah know when it's
time to let go of something and don't
let Financial Security more than
anything else don't let Financial
Security stand the way of growth and
opportunity interesting so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
thank you